I have ongoing regret for never joining
the military or police department and
I'm not yet strong enough to consider
changing careers now for financial
reasons.
I also don't know how to discuss this
with my wife as we want to make some
additions to the family soon.
I feel unfulfilled in the
single aspect of my life.
It's a strange feeling considering I have
skyrocketed up the chain in my company
so quickly,
so many would do anything
to be where I find myself.
How do you overcome your face or how do
you overcome or face yourself knowing
you're holding back
from a certain calling?
Because I really do see it
as a calling in some form.
I'm interested to hear from you.
I think this is pretty easy. Go
join the reserves. Hmm. Go join.
The reserves would be go in
the army reserves go in there.
They're like every branch has some
reserves where you're going to do one week
and month. You have to do
bootcamp. That'll be whatever.
It's going to be 10 weeks,
12 weeks, 14 weeks, depending
on which branch you go into.
And then you do one weekend a month and
you do two weeks in the summer. You,
you'll understand what the military is
about. There's actually a chance, well,
first of all, there's chance you'd be
deployed. I mean, when we were in Iraq,
you know, when we deployed to Ramadi,
my second deployment to Iraq, the,
the unit that was there,
the two to eight iron soldiers,
they were reserve unit
out of Pennsylvania.
They were awesome and they'd been there
for 14 months and they lost a lot of
guys and they fought hard.
So it's not like this reserve thing is a,
is is a different class,
a soldier,
they're soldiers for real.
They're marines for real.
Then you may be going on deployment.
Uh,
but what's cool about it is most
companies, they will excuse you.
Basically when you go in the reserves,
they'll excuse you when you have time.
And in fact, I think it's,
I was never in the reserves,
but I think you're actually protected by
the federal government from being fired
because you're serving in the reserves.
So I would definitely go and look into
the reserves because otherwise that
feeling that you have, I can only
imagine it's never going to go away.
I don't know.
Because I had that feeling that I wanted
to join the military when I was four
years old and I did it as soon
as I turned 18. So I don't,
you know, I didn't know what I regret
now. It was like I want to still be in,
you know, so especially now with
the fighting picking up overseas,
it's uh, you know, that's, that's the
only thing that, that I feel is damn,
I want to go back. But if you never did
it at all, that's a grinding feeling.
So go talk to a recruiter, getting
the reserves and you know what else?
In certain areas, there's definitely
volunteer fire departments. Yeah,
you can volunteer as a fireman and
you can volunteer as a policeman.
They have certain, uh, I don't know.
I have no idea what state you're
from asking this question.
But there's deputies you can get
deputized, you can go through a,
in San Diego they definitely have
reserved cops where you have to go to
[inaudible], you have to go to the police
academy and you become a reserve cop.
So, and with all that, um,
you want to talk about it with your
wife, talk about with your wife. Yeah.
You know,
you say you don't know how to,
this isn't a situation where you
can be totally honest with her, hey,
I always want to join the military.
I haven't done it.
I feel like it's something I really
want to do. Here's the options.
I want to go look at. What do you
think? Now you're, you're married,
you're married to a girl and
you're going to have kids.
It's your military service will be
harder on her than it is on you.
So she better be strong. She
better be tough. And you know, the,
the military wives out
there, I mean, my wife,
when I was gone on deployment after
deployment, it's not easy. I mean,
luckily she's tough and she raised
kids without me and she took care of
household without me and she went to the
hospital to visit my wounded guys and
she went to the funerals of my guys were
getting killed and she had to do that
while I was gone on deployment and I was,
she was hearing from me once a week maybe.
So you're going to put your
family through a lot of stress.
Now you might stress your family a lot
by always having regret that they held
you back. That's selfish. But that's true.
So I would just go look into it,
see what the options are,
talk about it with your wife.
There are some really good benefits to it.
And also the final point is sometimes
when you're reservist you can decide that
you want to go active duty. Maybe
you love it. Maybe you say, yeah,
this was my calling.
Maybe you're fourth day in boot
camp where you haven't slept.
You had your head shaved, you're tired,
you're hungry, the food is horrible.
And you say, man, this is what I've
always wanted to do with my life.
And if that happens, there's options
where you can now go active duty and,
and you can see how your wife
dealt with it while you were gone.
And if she dealt with it,
well that's great. Hey,
let's make a career out of this
and that's a good option to do.
So there's some that I think you're
this, this, this, this is easy day, easy,
easy problem to take care of.
No factor.